hey Lindsey heycord hi
hey I have an a bit of an unhealthy
obsession with Christmas movies it's
true but I loved this one it gave me
everything I wanted in a holiday film
Lindsay what was your favorite thing
about being back on set uh just the
atmosphere
um just getting to know everyone in the
crew and cast and and spending time with
people and having fun doing it I feel
like that's just always the best part is
just you have this immediate family that
you have and you just have fun with and
you make a movie and hope to make it
great
it's such a good movie you honestly look
like you have so much fun I love that
you show the bloopers at the end of
falling for Christmas card how would you
describe the energy that you will have
on set together
oh I feel like it was kind of like
immediate family and I think I mean me
for us not knowing each other really
going into it it was just one of those
things to where we just had a lot of fun
and it was really comfortable and easy
and uh everybody on set kind of set up
such a warm uh holiday environment that
it just felt like Christmas for two
months wherever Yeah Christmas forever
sequel
listen I want a sequel okay you're
putting that into the Universe I want
one with me too
um okay so I thought it'd be fun to do a
bit of like a holiday themed rapid fire
so tell me if you yes or no are you a
fan of eggnog yes
yes Lindsay no I haven't had it in so
long so maybe my taste buds have changed
maybe okay maybe give it another shot
what about fruitcake
no no
I know I'm like a Tiramisu girl
yes oh so good what about snow days what
do we like having snow days yeah
I'd love to know what you thought I said
but that's okay I thought you said snow
vase
oh yeah I thought it's noticed I thought
it was like a sweet or something
what about decorating
decorating for the holidays in November
I'm all for it
you're all for it cord offense so my
family has a tree up all year round I'm
not kidding and for like I'm not kidding
for like you know different holidays
whether it be Easter birthdays Father's
Day Mother's Day my mom puts if this is
the craziest thing ever but she puts
different pictures on the tree so if
it's somebody's birthday she'll call it
a birthday tree oh my God and then so
like we have a tree in our living room
this this is this has only happened
started the last year I don't know what
made her do this but this is it's like
now just called like
it's just everything it's the everything
tree I don't like The Giving Tree it's
it's I have to explain it to everybody
whenever I bring anybody to my parents
house it's so embarrassing but uh it's a
Giving Tree so much joy to her oh yeah I
mean she's she's in the Christmas spirit
year round
I love this okay Lindsay does your
family do something kind of specific
just to your family for the holidays
um I feel like the my mom always puts up
the stockings first before the tree even
gets there she gets really excited about
stocking stuffers so that's like a big
deal for my mom so that's one thing that
I carry with me
I love it stockings are I'm more excited
about stockings and actually unwrapping
presents so I totally feel that yeah
there's like little surprises and
there's so many more of them that's it
um and just as we're wrapping up
obviously Mean Girls feature the iconic
Jingle Bell Rock Dance theme if there
was a Mean Girls 2 what other holiday
song Would you love to perform with that
cast
oh that's a really good question that is
a good question
what's another good holiday song
Santa Baby Oh yeah Santa Baby that would
be a great one
yeah Santa that's a very good idea
that's hot
I just want a sequel and I want just
more Christmas music
so it's almost like another Christmas
movie right yes we're gonna make this
happen uh you both are so good in this
congratulations so nice seeing you too
thank you so much